a
eeuu y méxico han tenido una relación
histórica profunda en múltiples asuntos
pero ha sido una relación con muchos
altibajos mientras tanto se siguen
acumulando miles de inmigrantes en la
frontera común entre estos dos países
que esperan se aclare su situación para
poder entrar a eeuu de manera legal la
situación es muy complicada en la
frontera sobre todo desde que la
situación en américa latina' se ha
vuelto más crítica debido a las
consecuencias de la pandemia kobe 19 y
la violencia que presenta en algunos
países lo que ha forzado a muchas
personas a buscar en eeuu un nuevo
panorama en su futuro en su visita a la
ciudad de washington el presidente de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador
presentó un plan de cinco puntos para
poder mejorar la situación en la
frontera y también para mejorar la
relación con washington después de ese
desaire que provocó la ausencia del
mandatario mexicano en la cumbre de las
américas que tuvo lugar en los ángeles
en california veamos algunos de los
puntos que presentó la delegación
mexicana en esta visita a la casa blanca
el presidente de lópez obrador propuso
un aumento de visas temporales
disponibles para mano de obra calificada
también busca duplicar la producción de
gasolina en la zona de frontera en donde
hay una amplia diferencia entre los
precios que presentan los dos países por
supuesto de combustible en eeuu es mucho
más costoso que en méxico también méxico
ofreció poner a su disposición de la
disposición de eeuu más de 1.000
kilómetros de gasoducto en la frontera
sur para surtir otras regiones del país
norteamericano
el mandatario mexicano también propuso
eliminar los aranceles dentro del teme
que ese acuerdo comercial que firmaron
méxico eeuu y canadá también propuso un
plan de inversión pública y privada
entre los países así como mejorar la
infraestructura fronteriza
bueno pues por su parte el presidente de
eeuu joe biden afirmó que su país está
completamente comprometido para trabajar
y abordar esta crisis migratoria con
méxico país al que también identificó
como un país parque están al mismo nivel
en todos los términos sobre todo a nivel
comercial que recientemente pues se ha
convertido también en un destino para
migrantes así lo es méxico ahora también
es destino de muchos ciudadanos
centroamericanos venezolanos colombianos
y personas que vienen de otros puntos
también del caribe de áfrica tras el
encuentro que dan entonces para analizar
varios puntos por ejemplo la viabilidad
de este plan presentado por méxico que
también le puede llegar será llevarse a
cabo que representa a nivel político
para ambos países esta crisis migratoria
baiden con unas elecciones de medio
término a la vuelta de la esquina que
tanto está arriesgando con este tema y
el presidente mexicano el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador con unos
índices de violencia completamente
disparados en méxico porque le presta
más atención a estos temas comerciales
en vez de estar tratando esa compleja
situación interna que se está
presentando al interior de la república
mexicana el llegar a tener que tomar una
decisión en la frontera como estas que
se están planteando estos dos países
demuestra claramente que fracasó esa
política migratoria entre méxico y eeuu
pues lo vamos a analizar el día de hoy
en el debate de france 24 y también
veremos la situación interna en méxico
esa situación de violencia y de
inseguridad que se está presentando
sobre todo en los estados que están a lo
largo de la frontera con eeuu por eso
hemos invitado a montserrat martínez
téllez schellas coordinadora de
proyectos de global fault mx sobre ella
es especialista en desarme también es
doctor ante n políticas públicas de la
escuela de gobierno del tec de monterrey
pero ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
mexico en la capital de la república y
desde guadalajara se une a esta
conversación fernando jiménez sánchez él
es experto en seguridad también es
investigador del conap y de el colegio
de jalisco les recuerdo que ustedes
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar preguntas comentarios también en
sus en nuestras redes sociales a través
de sus redes sociales conectados con las
nuestras
peter instagram y facebook en donde no
se encuentran como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal y
les recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 también nos encuentran en
youtube para seguir esta señal en
streaming en vivo y en directo yo
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que también nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa ya están disponibles
en app el podcast spotify dize y zion
comienzo entonces el análisis comienzo
entonces con nuestra invitada montserrat
en la ciudad de mexico para comenzar a
hablar de este tema y primero el punto
de partida es decir la pregunta para
conocer opiniones de los invitados y
montserrat le preguntó por el balance
que se puede hacer de ese encuentro
entre el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador en la ciudad de washington con
el presidente de byd en y también sobre
la situación de seguridad que se está
viviendo en mexico que tal parece que no
es un tema prioritario para el
presidente mexicano como lo ve usted
me parece importante resaltar que esta
comunicación que buscan los o los
homólogos de estados unidos y de méxico
se
se enlaza en un ambiente de confianza en
un ambiente de querer solucionar
cuestiones
para ambos países tanto de cuestiones de
política de alto impacto y de alto de
nivel pero también cuestiones que al
final del día impactan a la ciudadanía
de manera cotidiana entonces me parece
que es un buen paso un pulmón por un
lado para tratar las cuestiones de
manera mucho más aterrizada sabiendo
cuáles son los intereses inmediatos y
por el otro también
para
e ir llevando estos temas a la agenda
internacional
pasó entonces a preguntarle a fernando
de la ciudad de guadalajara también hay
en la república mexicana punto de
partida fernando balance de esta reunión
entre el presidente de bailén y el
presidente de lópez obrador en términos
de inmigración que fue tal vez el tema
más importante de la agenda pero donde
también se hablaron de temas comerciales
y el tema de seguridad importante
analizarlo también
muy buenas tardes entre otras la
invitación
digamos que es una una reunión que creó
muchas expectativas y que al parecer los
resultados no van acorde con las
peticiones que tenía el gobierno
mexicano en un inicio
del comunicado último al listado de
opciones de solicitud de escribas al
gobierno mexicano pues no hay una no
está completo si se habla de la
migración evidentemente es un tema
conjunto pero no se no se deja en temas
muy específicos se creaban un grupo de
coordinación para atender el tráfico de
personas y bueno parece que la tónica va
a seguir siendo la misma el presidente
de lópez obrador les intenta de
securitizar la agenda bilateral cuando
el seguridad evidentemente es uno de los
elementos sustanciales de la relación
bilateral
montserrat tomó esa palabra de seguridad
que dice fernando y dejar el tema de la
seguridad de la es un tema que
compromete varios de los estados de la
república mexicana que tienen frontera
con eeuu por el tema de la frontera pues
pasan muchas cosas no solamente comercio
hay tráfico de personas al tráfico de
drogas hay un comercio ilegal es una
frontera como se dice muy caliente en
términos de delincuencia porque el
gobierno mexicano trata de minimizar un
poco el impacto de la inseguridad en
esta zona del país
me parece que no trata de minimizarlo y
por un lado hay que recordar que está en
marcha todavía el juicio por la demanda
de empresas de la industria almada en
eeuu y que ese es uno de los temas que
más le ha pegado a méxico en temas de
violencia de no solamente de inseguridad
de criminalidad común sino de crimen
organizado de armas de fuego y de este
de la violencia armada que puede suceder
en estas zonas que bien mencionas como
donde donde son más sensibles
no solamente al tráfico de personas al
tráfico de drogas al tráfico al comercio
ilícito sino que vemos mucho más
recurrentes temas de violencia armada
entonces me parece que hay que recordar
ella es pertinente y es un punto que
queda también sobre la mesa pendiente
pero me parece que el gobierno mexicano
lo que está haciendo es tratando de
esperar cuáles son las resoluciones de
las cortes allá en eeuu sobre el tema de
la demanda las industrias
de armamentos de eeuu con respecto de su
responsabilidad
en relación de cómo se origina el
tráfico ilícito de armas que terminan
afectando a la población en méxico claro
por supuesto en fernando en la ciudad de
guadalajara pasó a preguntarle ahora por
esos cinco puntos que presentó méxico
que presenta nada en la introducción del
programa y qué tan viable son estos
cinco puntos que también le puede méxico
llevar adelante esta agenda que recibió
pues prácticamente un respaldo por parte
de eeuu va a haber un fondo común entre
los dos países para el desarrollo de
infraestructura y para llevar a cabo
estos planes pero todo se queda en eso
en desembolso de dinero en planes y que
tanto se puede llevar a cabo
si a nivel fronterizo se queda al fondo
vamos a ver ya hoy el encargado de
inmigración en méxico informó que iba a
ser para infraestructura en los puntos
de cruce
vamos a ver hay muchas hay muchas
necesidades en la frontera norte en la
frontera sur de méxico son muy porosas
es necesario tener un mayor control y se
están muchos recursos entonces un paso
adelante ahora que sea suficiente pues
probablemente no y que la crisis
migratoria en mejores estados unidos
venga de cuestiones que son mucho más
grandes y
asegurar las fronteras que tienen que
ver con asuntos de desarrollo que tienen
que ver con asuntos propios de
criminalidad de violencia en méxico hoy
en sudamérica y de estos éxodos de
personas que están llegando y que están
intentando llegar a otra nación para oír
de más con nuestras posiciones muy
complicadas que viven en sus países esto
se intenta hacer de punto 9
derechos un marco de derechos humanos de
respeto a los derechos humanos pero si
no se da una noticia de algo
espectacularmente nuevo que sería lo que
se estaba esperando un cambio un
fortalecimiento
importante de la política migratoria y
no se presentó en este momento no sé si
en las próximas semanas tengamos nuevas
noticias ya de los grupos de trabajo y
de otros acuerdos que han llegado los
dos gobiernos en ese orden de ideas
fernando continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda la inversa
que tan crítico es este tema migratorio
para méxico que tan crítico y que tan
tanto peso le está ejerciendo esto al
gobierno del presidente lópez obrador
en sus políticas internas y en los
planes que él tenía dispuestos para su
gobierno
políticamente es muy complicado porque
tiene unos recursos los escasos recursos
de seguridad está en una parte
importante puestos en la frontera sur de
méxico que podrían estar siendo
utilizados para otras otras funciones
luego tienen las caravanas y todo lo que
conlleva de procurar los derechos de
todas estas personas que se están
moviendo
que no en todos los casos los
funcionarios
se han apegado a ellas con lo que ha
habido violencia y desorden que después
pues bueno implica violencia en contra
de las personas migrantes y
finalmente también implicaría por el
gobierno pues tiene un uno tiene
problemas serios humanitarios en la
frontera norte donde se queda la gran
población fuera de todos los todos los
problemas que acarrea las grandes
movilizaciones de personas dentro del
territorio nacional y toda la violencia
que se ejerce en contra de estas
reformas y los actos criminales en
contra de las personas migrantes todos
esos problemas y luego llegan al
frontera norte en donde se hace un
embudo y entonces crean toda una serie
de problemas humanitarios que tienen que
ver con la protección y la llegada de
estas miles de personas están esperando
poder pasar en eeuu y claro es
directamente toda una cuestión de
criminalidad asociada a las necesidades
de las personas migrantes que llegaron a
la frontera
montserrat hablamos de inversión
infraestructura en la frontera hablamos
de agilizar el proceso de las
solicitudes de asilo y de visas para las
personas que están allí represadas desde
que eeuu prácticamente que bloqueó la
frontera por el tema de la pandemia kobe
19 se habla también de un incremento en
el número de visas para los trabajadores
calificados pero dentro de estas cinco
propuestas no se habla del tema de
seguridad como es el tema de la
seguridad en la frontera como es el tema
de seguridad allí
y justo me parece que viene aparejado a
lo que nos comentaba anteriormente
como el tema de reunificación familiar
por ejemplo tampoco está señalado allí
sin embargo a realizar cierto tipo de
flujos podría ayudar a que no se
ejerciera violencia hacia poblaciones
por ejemplo que residen en méxico que
están en
que son mexicanas propiamente no para
que hagan este este paso en la frontera
particularmente bueno ya lo decíamos
méxico no solamente envía mexicanos a
eeuu es el paso propio para otro tipo de
poblaciones que vienen de centroamérica
de sudamerica del caribe para eeuu
entonces un punto importante es no
solamente la violencia que se ejerce por
parte de las fuerzas armadas o las
fuerzas de seguridad incluso en
cualquiera de los dos lados de la
frontera sino también la violencia que
criminal que se que se ejerce en esos
espacios y me parece que uno de los
puntos más sobresalientes fue el
hallazgo
tráiler en las últimas semanas con
personas que fallecieron y bueno algunas
fueron
afortunadamente fueron rescatadas pero
creo que ahí se evidencia la situación
doble de violencia que están viviendo
las personas migrantes que intentan
cruzar hacia el otro lado que es el tema
no solamente de la violencia por parte
de las fuerzas del estado sino también
de las fuerzas criminales entonces si es
un tema importante ya este tema de la
seguridad y la presencia de estos grupos
criminales allí en la frontera
usted cita este tema de los 53 migrantes
encontrados asfixiados en un en un
trailer en el estado de texas eso
también le podemos sumar cierto descuido
de las autoridades y también a una alta
corrupción que se ve dentro de las
autoridades de ambos países porque la
frontera es común que hay de la
corrupción allí a nivel fronterizo
me parece que de ambos lados como
decíamos hay problemas sobre qué es lo
que se espera de estos flujos
migratorios y si claro que es importante
estos espacios por ejemplo ahora con la
visita que se hizo entre entre los
ejecutivos homólogos de eeuu y de iu de
méxico me parece que es importante
identificar cuál es la visión en
conjunto cuál es la visión en común que
se tiene y también es importante
recordar que al final del día en eeuu
hay un dicho que nos dice o politics es
local y tiene que ver mucho también con
la percepción que se tiene en el cruce
en ciertos estados por ejemplo
entre méxico y eeuu en donde quizá no es
también recibida estos flujos
migratorios y en donde también hay mucho
más
y tranquilidad al momento de recibir
estos flujos migratorios porque se
espera que estas personas lleguen a
trabajar lleguen a hacer ciertas labores
entonces sí creo que es muy importante
decidir cómo identificar cuáles son los
puntos en común y qué se espera de estos
flujos migratorios para entonces ahí
trazar una estrategia que pueda
prevenir temas de corrupción por parte
de ambas autoridades fernando su opinión
sobre este tema la corrupción que hay en
la en la zona fronteriza por parte de
las dos de las dos naciones mencionaba
puntualmente el caso de estos 53
migrantes encontrados en el trailer en
el estado de texas muestra también una
digámoslo así una fallida política
migratoria por parte de los dos países
la situación se ha salido de las manos
en algunos momentos y como por ejemplo
en esta coyuntura en la que estamos
hombre es un ejemplo de los miles de
miles de los actos que se están dando en
territorio de eeuu para el control de
las personas migrantes entonces sí
estamos hablando de que seguramente hay
actos de corrupción en algún momento ya
eran personas que ya están por eeuu y
que se están movilizando internamente
pero es evidente que las personas llegan
a chicago y llegan a nueva york es bueno
tuvimos que recorrer todo el país para
llegar allá si es que llegaron por la
frontera sur de estados unidos entonces
si eso es un tema muy complejo porque
aparte los gobernadores han tenido una
actitud
fuerte en el tema enfrentados con el
presidente de byd en donde toman la
iniciativa para cerrar las fronteras
para convocar a la guardia nacional para
ser llamados
qué
y movilicen a la población en contra del
gobierno federal y en cierta forma
podemos decir que no no tienen los
mismos
la misma agenda que los gobernadores
todo esto también tiene que ver con el
proceso electoral que se vive en eeuu
pero claro para que para que estas
personas estén llegando a la ciudad
desde el norte pues tiene que haber una
movilización interna en donde
seguramente hay autoridades de eeuu que
se están prestando actos de corrupción y
son parte de estas de estas redes de
tráfico de personas hablemos de la
coyuntura interna de los dos países para
ponernos en contexto montserrat en
muchos medios mexicanos y algunos
analistas han dicho que esta visita le
vino perfecto al presidente mexicano
después de ese desaire sin pase que tuvo
con washington al no presentarse en la
cumbre de las américas en los ángeles y
haberle dado un respaldo a nicaragua
venezuela
y cuba porque no fueron invitados a esta
cumbre continental
cuál es la coyuntura ya lo que se está
enfrentando el presidente mexicano al
interior de su país sobre todo cuando el
país está teniendo algunos problemas
económicos para recuperarse después de
las tierras que tuvo que hacer por por
la pandemia de kobe 19 y la alta
inflación que se está presentando
también allí
me parece que lo que está haciendo esta
visita específicamente es el presidente
del presidente de méxico está poniendo
en claro cuáles son las prioridades
atender
respecto a la relación bilateral entre
méxico y eeuu y que finalmente en el
tema regional
pasa a segundo término por la urgencia
de los aspectos coyunturales y
contextuales sobre todo en temas de
seguridad y de violencia que atraviesan
nuestro país y en donde eeuu termina
siendo un actor clave
para para intentar atenderlos entonces
me parece por este lado que el
presidente está dejando claro con esta
visita cuáles son los intereses a tener
cuáles son los puntos más urgentes y qué
tiene que ver con un tema coyuntural
sobre este sobre condiciones de
seguridad y violencia y que al final del
día también vemos dónde está el apoyo
también ideológico de a dónde les
gustaría por ejemplo al ejecutivo
federal hacia dónde le gustaría dirigir
sus políticas públicas entonces me
parece que es
muy clara la postura de parte del
presidente de méxico fernando montserrat
habla de prioridades y de puntos
urgentes para atender en méxico lo que
usted quiere añadir de la coyuntura
mexicana para entender en qué contexto
ocurre esta visita y también lo que nos
puede aportar desde el otro lado la
frontera al lado de eeuu yo ya lo
mencionaba la introducción byte en esta
con unas elecciones de medio término a
la vuelta de la esquina que tanto peso
este tema migratorio le va a generar
problemas al presidente para pues no
sabemos cuál va a ser la votación pero
que pueda perder la mayoría en por lo
menos en la cámara de representantes de
su bancada demócrata
estamos en un desequilibrio de
popularidad del presiente mexicano llega
con mucho apoyo de la población a
mientras que en eeuu pues bueno vayan se
presenta con los niveles más bajos
claro el proceso electoral lo está
marcando bailén no sé es difícil le
podría costar muchos puntos tratar el
tema migratorio de otra forma
enfrentaría a cierto electorado que no
está muy en de acuerdo en la situación
que se vive de migratorio y en mejorar
las condiciones de la agenda migratoria
para alinearlas con las solicitudes
mexicanas y
[Música]
facilitar todo este proceso por un lado
por otro lado con méxico siempre está un
presidente que está fortalecido que
todavía queda la mitad del mandato y que
tiene tiene prioridades y vuelvo al
punto está con una campaña digamos de
quitar la seguridad del tema principal
en la relación bilateral y en la
política interna del país y creo que en
cierta forma lo logra los beneficios de
la visita después de la cumbre que no
asistió el presidente mexicano pues
bueno lo que nos habla es que hay una
muy buena relación ya que él fue a eeuu
podría a poner su agenda aunque no haya
salido del todo victoria caso pero bueno
algunos de los temas se tocan el
problema los fertilizantes se solucionan
en cierta medida el gobierno por su nos
va a pegar fertilizantes o de vender
espero utilizarse al gobierno de mexico
y también hay un asunto con la leche y
bueno ahí hay ciertos temas que ayudaran
esperemos a la relación y a las
condiciones de la población y el
desarrollo del país
fernando usted toca ya el tema comercial
habla del tema de los fertilizantes
también de inversión entre los dos
países sigue méxico muy enfocado en este
aliado estratégico que es a nivel
comercial eeuu para la república
mexicana y se está dejando de lado tal
vez otros países donde méxico podría
tener una mayor influencia esto hablando
en los países centroamericanos y también
por qué no una mayor integración con los
países suramericanos que no es que no
está integrado hace parte de muchos
escenarios de toma de decisión y de y de
intercambio comercial como por ejemplo
la alianza del pacífico pero pero méxico
le cuesta un poco integrarse américa
latina y esto reitera que siempre se
enfoca en términos comerciales hacia
eeuu y en menor medida canadá
es un gobierno que fue es muy latino
américa y latinoamericanista pero la
realidad de los pandémica y la crisis de
las cadenas de distribución pues dejaron
en vivo la
dependencia que existe comercial entre
las dos naciones y la importancia de
méxico para la economía de eeuu y de
eeuu para méxico
yo creo que fue es un momento en el que
queda muy claro la necesidad de los dos
países para salir adelante y pues por
ahí tendrán tendrá que tendrá que ir la
relación de los próximos años y una vez
que ya se establezca
mejor para las dos naciones como de
digamos pues probablemente sí puedan
podemos voltear con más energía hacia
latinoamérica aguas hace falta
centroamérica pero los esfuerzos del
gobierno mexicano hacia centroamérica y
hacia latinoamérica han sido grandes en
comparación con los gobiernos anteriores
sí eso queda en evidencia en esa visita
que hizo el presidente mexicano a unos
países centroamericanos y también
incluida la isla de cuba montserrat su
opinión sobre este tema este enfoque
comercial este gran esfuerzo del
gobierno mexicano de mantener a eeuu
como su gran aliado y pues dar lo estaba
mencionando yo dejando un poco de lado
esa relación natural que debe tener con
latinoamérica
me parece que es importante otra vez
recordar como el volumen de comercio que
hay hacia eeuu y entre méxico y eeuu
también por otro lado por ejemplo
esfuerzos como la alianza del pacífico
ponen en evidencia cómo ir encontrando
estos espacios estas áreas de
oportunidad para que haya una mayor
integración y ya no solamente estamos
hablando de temas comerciales estamos
hablando de capital humano no de las
personas de cómo podemos integrar la
región latinoamericana con estos saberes
con estos conocimientos que ya se tienen
con este desarrollo por ejemplo
tecnológico con este desarrollo de
cuáles son las oportunidades que hay
entre méxico y el resto de latinoamérica
entonces si bien si efectivamente se ha
priorizado por el volumen del comercio y
de las relaciones económicas que hay
hacia américa del norte es importante
decir que hay una mirada y todavía si
este interés hacia hacia una integración
con con el resto de américa latina pero
ya no solamente en términos comerciales
en términos también de flujo de
cultural y el flujo de personas y en
flujo es una integración mucho más
podríamos decir holística y que no
solamente se enfoca en temas económicos
entonces me parece que poco a poco
conforme vaya superando se estos
espacios con view coyunturales y como ya
decíamos en temas de violencia en temas
de seguridad
poco a poco se puede ir diversificando
en estas áreas de oportunidad y es
inglés que hay hacia el resto de la
integración en la región montserrat
continuo con usted no le parece a usted
que méxico está haciendo está perdiendo
una oportunidad valiosísima de ser
precisamente el puente entre eeuu y
otros países de latinoamérica hace de
ese país que permita mejorar el diálogo
con esos países que son un poco más
cercanos a méxico está hablando de
venezuela nicaragua cuba con por ejemplo
en el caso de venezuela pues eeuu está
tratando de mejorar la relación poco a
poco podría méxico jugaron un rol qué
tal vez se lo está perdiendo en este
momento de ser un actor mucho más
influyente en ese tipo de acercamientos
me parece que méxico siempre se ha
caracterizado por ser este actor neutral
en donde se pueden abrir conversaciones
entre países entre gobiernos que muchas
veces tienen posturas disímiles de cómo
atender ciertos ciertos desafíos y
ciertas cuestiones dentro de la región
me parece que méxico todavía tiene esta
oportunidad de continuar con el
liderazgo y ya no los ha mostrado con
temas que son bastante coyunturales no
solamente para méxico sino para la
región de américa latina el tema de otra
vez temas de violencia armada a temas de
desarrollo me parece que méxico ha
intentado seguir siendo la punta de
lanza y quizá en esto en esta relación
bilateral
si bien se están tratando como temas muy
puntuales que afectan directamente a la
ciudadanía en ambos países en foros
multilaterales se ha visto es el
liderazgo
en donde se acompañan procesos en temas
de seguridad y de violencia para américa
latina fernando hemos hablado del tema
de la frontera norte la frontera común
entre méxico de eeuu pues porque
obviamente eeuu está
interesado en que méxico tome acciones
allí para controlar un poco el flujo
migratorio pero que hay de la frontera
sur se quedó tal vez por fuera de la
agenda tomar medidas para esta frontera
que también a méxico le ha costado un
poco mantener el control allí con esta
gran cantidad de migrantes que llegan a
las diferentes caravanas no solamente
desde el triángulo del norte en
centroamérica sino personas que vienen
originando su viaje desde suramérica y a
méxico le ha costado un poco estar allí
haciendo presencia
para regresar a todas estas personas que
están llegando a méxico como el país de
espera mientras se soluciona su
situación migratoria
si la
frontera sur es muy compleja méxico le
está apostando a
controlar la frontera a ordenar los
flujos
digamos en cierta forma de quitar
probablemente de las manos criminales a
todas estas personas todas las rutas
abriendo los caminos en cierta forma
está protegidos por las autoridades
la apuesta es a los programas sociales o
sea méxico tiene una inversión fuerte
política y económica en sembrando vidas
en los programas sociales tiene méxico
que se está intentando exportar a
centroamérica con el apoyo de eeuu para
atacar digamos las razones por las que
se mueven las personas por lo menos los
suelos los países colindantes con
mexicanos 3
para poder así disminuir los los flujos
migratorios hay un despliegue muy
importante un operativo muy importante
de la guardia nacional en la frontera
sur de méxico y entonces con eso se está
intentando detener ahí las imágenes son
muy claras con las caravanas y siempre
acompañadas por la autoridad la
autoridad no ha querido
afortunadamente cerrarlas y utilizar la
violencia en contra de las personas
migrantes que creo que es un acierto muy
grande y procurar sus sus derechos para
este último tramo del del programa me
enfoco en el tema de seguridad ya me
quedan pocos minutos para acabar el
análisis y montserrat el retoma el tema
de la seguridad y quiero hablar de
algunos comentarios que han hecho varios
periodistas mexicanos diciendo que el
presidente lópez obrador prácticamente
ha cedido ante el poder de los cárteles
mexicanos y entre el poder de las bandas
delincuenciales a lo largo y ancho de la
república mexicana que tan cierto es
esto que cese de terrenos
las fuerzas militares mexicanas están
muy permeadas por la corrupción y por
estos mismos grupos delincuenciales
me parece que por un lado méxico también
le ha apostado la colaboración
internacional y permítanme decirlo de
esta manera méxico es parte de muchos
foros internacionales en donde
constantemente se está viendo por el
intercambio de información por ejemplo
para controlar temas sobre comercio de
armas entonces méxico en ese sentido ha
apostado por que los mecanismos
internacionales sean los que ayuden a
dar un poco este cobijo y también por
otro lado si bien las estrategias no son
de enfrentamientos armados se está
buscando cómo hacer labores de
inteligencia que permitan minimizar
estas cuestiones por ejemplo hemos visto
que durante estos años ha habido mucho
fuego cruzado en donde la mayor parte
de las personas afectadas de las
víctimas ha sido población civil que
estaban en espacios en fuego cruzado
entre criminales entre fuerzas armadas
entonces si vemos la estrategia está
apostando por una gestión mucho más
sobre labores de inteligencia
colaboración y cooperación a nivel
internacional de tal manera que este
marco pueda ayudar un poco la condene la
situación ya al interior de nuestro país
fernando rápidamente su opinión sobre
este tema antes de dar paso a las
conclusiones
las críticas han sido muy grandes
estamos muy estamos acostumbrados a otro
tipo de estrategias a unas estrategias
más policiales de enfrentamiento de
comunicación también hemos tenido dos
presidentes anteriores que se dedicaron
a comunicar en seguridad se volvían bono
monotemáticos entonces nosotros tenemos
un presidente que actualmente pues abrió
la agenda y esto también causa un
descontrol absoluto en la población y en
el entender la estrategia por el momento
pues hay una guardia nacional el cuerpo
policial nuevo está militarizado algunos
lo llaman así a algunos les gusta a
otros no aprobarán es lo que hay y hay
toda una serie de
estrategias paralelas o de elementos que
se juntan que buscan hacer tener
incidencia en los lugares más donde se
presenta el mayor número de delitos hay
mucho que hacer pero pues ahí está la
parte final del programa vamos entonces
con las conclusiones comienzo con
montserrat en su conclusión de lo que
deja este encuentro en washington entre
el presidente de méxico del presidente
estado entre otros temas pues ya lo
decíamos abordar el tema migratorio el
tema de la seguridad
me parece que méxico va con una idea muy
clara que son los temas que quiere
tratar que puede que tiene que tiene
idea de que estos se pueden avanzar y se
pueden implementar no solamente es una
lista de deseos sobre todo lo que se
quiere resolver sino más bien es una
lista muy puntual de hacia dónde se
quieren dirigir los pasos y me parece
que ese es un gran primer paso para
saber si se pueden aterrizar y se pueden
hacer acciones más completas y más
concretas y también me parece importante
enfatizar que si que si está marcado en
una coyuntura muy particular sobre
esta costa este cuestionamiento que se
ha dado a partir de que se encontró por
ejemplo el tráiler de los 53 migrantes
entonces obedece a cuestiones
coyunturales pero también obedece a esta
cuestión de que la que sea práctico
efectivo y que se implemente en acciones
concretas la conclusión de montserrat
fernando cuál es su conclusión de este
encuentro este tema bilateral de la
crisis migratoria la frontera entre
méxico y eeuu
pues la primera es que sigue habiendo un
interés importante de las donaciones en
resolver los problemas de forma común
aceptar abrir la agenda más allá de la
seguridad es un buen paso no se ha
llegado a concretar exactamente lo que
se buscaba pero hay avances en otros
temas que seguramente se seguirán
trabajando en los próximos meses y se
verá como estas agendas de seguridad de
migración pues probablemente encuentren
unos mejores espacios y unos mejores
momentos para ser debatidas
tendremos que esperar yo porque en las
próximas semanas podemos tener mayores
noticias sobre consecuencias de este
encuentro
pero sí fue muy bueno abrió hoy
demuestra la hermandad a las dos
naciones pues a montserrat ya fernando
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa haber hecho este
análisis del panorama de seguridad y la
situación coyuntural en méxico y este el
balance de este encuentro entre los dos
presidentes en los presidentes de méxico
de eeuu ustedes pueden seguir dejando
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales y pueden
seguir en sintonía con la programación
de france 24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]